Und Eidin?
Eidin, genau.
Y, Dora, Idan, Nordpol.
Okay, verstehe.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Eidin?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Wie alt sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 28. April, 1900.
Was ist das, 83?
Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich glaube, 1,83 m.
Und wie viel wiegen Sie?
So circa 75 kg.
Herr Eidin, was führt Sie zu uns?
Frau Doktor, Sie sehen, ich habe einen ganz schiefen Kopf.
Ich habe Schmerzen am linken Arm.
Seit heute habe ich so kröne und eine Schwäche im Arm.
Aber extreme Rückenschmerzen.
Ich kann schon nicht mehr richtig schlafen,
die heute Nacht habe ich überhaupt nicht geschlafen,
weil ich so starke Schmerzen am Rücken habe.
Sie haben am Rücken und im linken Arm Schmerzen?
Ja.
Und auch das Gefühl im Arm und Handel?
Ja, ja, ja. Also hier unten und an den beiden Fingern hier.
Das ist ganz schön.
Haben Sie auch Krippe?
Ja, ja.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerde?
Das sind zwei Wochen, aber seit zwei Tagen ist es ganz, ganz, ganz schlimm geworden.
Keine Schmerz-Tabletten helfen mir.
Egal, wie viel ich nehme, ich habe schon Bargeschmerzen.
Und das hilft nichts.
Was haben Sie eingegangen gegen diese Schmerzen?
Also ich habe zu Hause Ibuprofen gehabt und Paracetamol.
Ich habe beides eingenommen, aber das hilft mir nicht mehr.
Wie stark sind diese Ibuprofen 600 oder 400 mg?
Ich glaube, das waren Ibuprofen, ich meine 800.
Davon habe ich pro Tag drei, vier Stück genommen.
Und danach zusätzlich Paracetamol.
500 mg?
Ich glaube, das sind 500 mg, ja.
Aber es hat leider nicht geholfen.
Hat Ihr Hausarzt verschreiben diese Ibuprofen?
Nein, ich habe das zu Hause gehabt.
Ich habe es von mir aus genommen.
Der Hausarzt ist leider in Urlaub.
Wir sind jetzt in den Feiertage, der hat Urlaub.
Ja, ich verstehe.
Ich konnte nicht zum Hausarzt gehen.
Ich verstehe.
Es ist gut, dass Sie ins kranken Haus gekommen sind.
Ja, den musste ich heute kommen.
Es waren immer noch ganz schlimme Schmerzen.
Sie sehen, mein Hals ist ganz schief.
Ich kann schon den Kopf nicht mehr bewegen.
Ich verstehe.
Sind diese Schmerzen langsam oder plötzlich begonnen?
Also vor zwei Wochen langsam.
Ich habe auch letzte Woche mit meinen Freunden Fußball gespielt.
Danach waren sie auch weg.
Ich konnte sehr gut schlafen.
Aber seit drei, vier Tagen ist es akut, wieder ganz schlimm geworden.
Am Anfang waren diese Schmerzen auch im Rücken und im Linken.
Nein, im Arm nicht, nur im Rücken.
Am Anfang nur im Rücken.
Am Anfang nur im Rücken, ja.
Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen?
Einer Schmerz kann auch ein sehr leichter und sehr starken Schmerz.
Jetzt würde ich sagen neun bis zehn.
Das sind Höllenschmerzen.
Können Sie diese Schmerzen jetzt ertragen?
Oder brauchen Sie jetzt auch ein Schmerz?
Wenn Sie mir jetzt eine Spritze geben können,
wäre ich Ihnen sehr dankbar.
Es ist auch ganz schlimm.
Ich halte es nicht mehr aus.
Okay, Sie bekommen gleich eines.
Aber können Sie mir bitte so einiges sagen,
ob Sie gegen eine bestimmte Medikamente allergisch sind?
Nein, allergien habe ich keine.
Okay, Sie bekommen jetzt einen Schmerz.
Okay, aber vielen Dank.
Das ist aber ganz gut.
Die Schmerzen lassen ein bisschen nach, aber sind immer noch da.
Ich hoffe, dass es dann besser wird.
Ich verstehe, gibt es einen bestimmten Auflöser für diese Schmerzen?
Ich kann nicht sagen.
Also egal, was ich mache, ob ich mich auf die Seite lege,
sitze oder schlafe, egal in welche Position,
es tut alles weh.
Gibt es nicht, wie sich Schmerzen hindert oder verstellt?
Nein.
Ein Bewegung oder hindert?
Wenn ich ein bisschen Wärme habe,
dann meine ich, dass es etwas besser wird.
Aber es kommt wieder an.
Wenn ich mich in einer Position sitze, dann geht es mir 10 Minuten gut,
aber dann muss ich wieder schnell die Position ändern.
Können Sie Ihren Arm in aller Richtung normal bewegen?
Also nur ganz wenig, mehr geht nicht, da tut das weh.
Haben Sie eine Schwerte von der Hand noch einmal?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal, so etwas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ich möchte zusammenpassen, Sie haben eine Schmerz im Rücken
und am linken Arm.
Auch Sie haben Topheizgefühl und Liebe am Arm
und Finger und Hände.
Nur die linke Hand.
Seit zwei Wochen haben Sie diese Schmerzen
und seit drei Tagen diese Schmerzen schlimmer geworden.
Ja, ganz genau.
Haben Sie noch Handelübungen?
Also ich habe auch so ein bisschen Magenschmerzen,
ich denke, weil ich so viele Medikamente genommen habe
und eine leichte Übelkeit.
Haben Sie Magenschutz?
Nein, leider nicht, habe ich nicht gehabt.
Haben Sie früher schon ähnliche Magenschmerzen?
Nein, ist mir auch nicht bekannt.
Ich habe auch noch nie so viele Schmerzmedikamente genommen.
Können Sie mir die Schmerzen genauer beschreiben,
sind Sie eher dumpf, drückend, stehend oder...
Nein, stehend, eher stehend.
So richtig wie ein Messer strahlt es manchmal rein.
Aber wie gesagt, Rückenschmerzen
und das Strahlt in den Arm aus.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Übelkeit haben.
Haben Sie Erbrochen?
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie Durchfall?
Nein.
Herr Eiden, rufen Sie?
Haben Sie nicht gerafft?
Nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich trinke keinen Alkohol.
Bitte nehmen Sie meine nächste Frage nicht persönlich.
Routine-mäßig muss ich Sie fragen, ob Sie irgendeine Kontakte
mit Drogen hatten oder haben.
Nein.
Meine schlimmste Droge sind HW-Bost, Gummibergen.
Da kann ich mich kaum zurückhalten.
Ich verstehe.
Herr Eiden, haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Haben Sie nachts Schweiß oder Arschdörferost?
Nein, nein.
Wie ist Ihr Apetit in der Sterseite?
Ja, jetzt mit den Schmerzen ein bisschen weniger,
aber sonst normalerweise gut.
Ich verstehe.
Haben Sie in der Sterseite Gewicht
so genommen oder abgenommen?
Nein, es ist eigentlich immer gleich gegeben.
Haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Normalerweise nicht, aber die letzte Nacht
habe ich nicht mehr überwacht,
weil ich nicht mehr schmerze.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen
oder durchschlafen oder beides?
Normalerweise nicht, nein.
Und jetzt beim Einschlafen?
Also jetzt konnte ich nicht schlafen
wegen Schmerzen, aber normalerweise habe ich
diese Probleme nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme mit dem Sturrgang
oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, nein, ich habe keine Vorerkrankungen.
Nein, bisher war ich teuer, teuer, teuer, gesund.
Ich verstehe das sehr gut.
Und haben Sie schon einmal öppert worden?
Ob ich einmal öppert worden bin,
ich hatte vor fünf Jahren
eine Erkrankung,
und ich habe mich nicht mehr überwacht.
Ich habe mich nicht mehr überwacht,
aber ich habe mich nicht mehr überwacht.
Ich hatte vor fünf Jahren
eine kleine Kinnerooperation,
da habe ich schon Miniskuss-Riss gehabt
nach dem Fußballspiel.
Sie spielen Fußball professionell?
Nein, das ist als Hobby.
Und noch andere Operationen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nur diese Miniskuss-Riss?
War diese Operation offensiv?
Minimal die invasive Eingriff.
Ich verstehe.
Und Komplikationslosverlust?
Ja, ich weiß, es ist alles gut für den Lauf.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig Medikamente
oder diese genannte Ibuprofen?
Nein, nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Nein.
Haben Sie irgendeine Erkrankung oder Verträglichkeit?
Nein, bisher nicht bekannt.
Was sind Sie von Beruf vereint?
Ich bin IT-er, also Informatiker.
Müssen Sie viel Gesessen im Arbeit?
Ja, ich sitze überwiegend vor den Computern,
da stimmt, ich habe wenig Bewegung.
Ich habe auch ein bisschen Sport, also mit Fußball spielen.
Das tut mir immer ganz gut.
Wie viel Stunden arbeiten Sie, Taxüber?
Ja, 8 bis 10 Stunden, das ist bei uns Routine.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja, ich bin verheiratet und habe 2 kleine Kinder.
Sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Ja, glücklicherweise, sie sind gesund.
Sind Sie regelmäßig Sport-Auser, die Fußballspiele?
Nein, sonst nicht.
Und ist diese Fußball regelmäßig?
Nein, das machen wir alle 2 Wochen.
Waren Sie in Letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein.
Wir waren nur im letzten Sommer, kurz mal in Italien,
aber ansonsten nicht.
Sie waren nicht in der Türkei?
Nein, wir waren in Italien.
Ich verstehe.
Und haben Sie in Letzter Zeit einen Unfall?
Unfall? Nein, Unfall habe ich nicht gehabt.
Und jetzt möchte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer Familie stellen.
Bitte, ich stelle Sie schnell,
da ich die Schmerzen nehme, jetzt wieder zu.
Ich verstehe.
Vielen Dank für Ihre Geduld.
Aber ich muss diese Fragen.
Beeiligen Sie sich bitte.
Leiden Ihrer Familie mit Glieder an irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Nein, nur Freunde.
Nein, so weiss ich, ich weiss nicht.
Keine Erkrankungen.
Das ist sehr gut.
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Er ist gesund, ja, der Junge, als ich.
Ich weiss, dass er jetzt keine Erkrankungen.
Sie sind alle gesund, das ist sehr gut.
Ja, glücklicherweise bisher haben wir keine größeren Problemen gehabt.
Das war auch so ich jetzt.
Ich werde wieder gesund sein.
Ich hoffe, ich wäre Ihnen sehr dankbar,
dass Sie mir helfen, dass die Schmerzen weggehen.
Dann bin ich sehr dankbar.
Wir werden Ihnen helfen, keine Sorgen bittet.
Okay, danke schön.
Jetzt würde ich Sie bitten, noch einmal kurz im Martinsmalplatz zu nehmen.
Wir rufen Sie in wenigen Minuten mit der Untersuchung an.
Danke.
Ich würde Sie bitten, noch einmal kurz im Martinsmalplatz zu nehmen.
Wir rufen Sie in wenigen Minuten mit der Untersuchung an.
Danke schön.
Aber bitte lassen Sie mich nicht lange warten.
Okay, wir beeilen uns.
Okay.
Danke schön, Frau Doktor, Sie sind eine ganz nette Ärztin.
Danke schön.
Sehr gut. Sonst noch Fragen von den Kollegen?
Ich habe vergessen,
dass Sie eine sehr gute Frage haben.
Nein, nein.
Danke schön.
Ja, wir haben eine gute Frage.
Darf ich eine Frage?
Aber natürlich, bitte schön.
Haben Sie eine gute Frage?
Einige Gefühle.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Danke.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ja, bitte schön.
Haben Sie Schwache in ihren Armen oder in ihren Beinen bemerkt?
Eine Schwache.
Eine Schwäche?
Eine Schwäche.
Nur, wie gesagt, der linke Arm, wo es weh tut, ist auch ein bisschen schwach.
Aber in den Beinen habe ich jetzt keine Probleme, nein.
Im Gesicht nicht, nein.
Ich kann nur meinen Kopf nur, da ist es schlecht bewegen.
Aber da habe ich jetzt nicht, nein.
Danke.
Haben Sie auch Neck und Schmerzen?
Nein, also die Schmerzen sind zwischen den Schulterblättern am meisten.
Aber ja, klar, der Neck ist auch ein bisschen verspannt,
weil ich den Kopf nicht so richtig bewegen kann.
Aber die meisten Schmerzen sind zwischen den Schulterblättern
und wie gesagt, der Arm.
Keine Fragen, dann machen wir weiter, oder?
Brauchen Sie noch ein bisschen Zeit, Frau Doktor?
Eine Minute.
Sie können das schon ganz gut.
Ich glaube, Sie brauchen nicht so viel Zeit.
Minuten ist rum.
Herr Oberarzt, ich würde Ihnen gerne einen Patienten vorstellen,
den ich gerade in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe.
Haben Sie so viel Zeit?
Aber Sie doch immer, Frau Doktor, natürlich.
Bitte schön.
Stell Sie mal vor, was haben Sie, oder wen haben Sie aufgenommen?
Was sind die Probleme? Erzählen Sie mal.
Herr Said Aydin, 42 Jahre,
100, 83 cm groß
und 75 kg Schwer.
Der Patienten ist 40, bei uns vor aufgehend Zeit.
2 Wochen, 5 Tage, aber seit 2 Tagen
Schlimmer gewordener, langsam aufgetretener.
Die Patienten sind im Rückenbereich
und im linken Arm.
Der Patienten berechnet
die Schmerz, die die Schmerz haben.
Der Patienten berichtet über
die Hippe und die Parästhe
am linken Arm und linken Hände
und linken Finger.
Die linken Hände ist plural.
Die linken Hände und linken Finger.
Den kleinen Finger.
Die Schmerz interessiert,
wo die Schmerz auf die Hippe und linken Finger sind.
wo die mit 9 Fronten auf der Schmerzskala bewerben.
Der Patienten,
die HWG gendiert,
die Schmerz im Ibuprofen 600 mg,
4 Malz und Paracetamol 500 mg,
4 Malz eingenommen.
4 Mal, nicht 4 Malz, oder mehr Malz.
Mehr Malz, oder mehr Malz.
Der Patient fügt den Hinzu,
dass er ein Bewegungseinschränkungen
im linken Arm habe.
Und auch er fügt den Hinzu,
dass Wärme etwas besser gemacht
die Schmerzen.
Dass die Schmerzen besser wurden
oder dass die Schmerzen sich
lindert hätten.
Okay.
Begleitend auf
der Patient über Magenschmerzen.
Sie denken, er denke,
dass die Schmerzen, Magenschmerzen
gegen diese Medikamente
wegen dieser Medikamente
habe.
Und RHAB A ein bisschen überkommt,
die Frage,
nach EMEZIS, Diarrheu
und Ödem in den betroffenen Bereich
rücken und in den linken Arm.
Die vegetative Anamnese
ist unanfällig bis auf
schmerzbedingte Inapätenz
und auf schmerzbedingte
Medikamente.
Der Patient hatte keine Vorerkrankungen.
Er sei
gen menusküs ruptur
vor fünf Jahren operiert worden.
Der Patient,
wir waren noch mit der Satz nochmal.
Wiederholen bitte.
Der Patient.
Er war nicht traucher,
nie traucher,
trinke keine Alkohol
und verneinte Drogenkonsum.
Er war nicht traurig,
aber er war nicht traurig.
Er war herzlich informatiker
und eine 1991 Live,
er müsste viel szenen
wegen des Arbeits?
Er müsste viel szenen
wegen des Arbeits.
Er er Fraser
jetzt sehtunzehn hundert minute
Er sei verheiratet und habe zwei gesunde kleine Kinder.
Er spiele alle zwei Wochen Fußball.
Fußball, ja.
Ich habe keine Aufmerksamkeit in der Familienanamnese.
Aufgrund der Symptomatik habe ich einen Verdacht auf,
als wir sollen Diskusprodups.
Sehr gut, würde ich auch sagen.
Können Sie auch ungefähr einschätzen, in welcher Höhe?
Nein, ich kann nicht einschätzen.
Ist es die oberen HWS, untere HWS?
Wie die Dermatome sind ungefähr.
Man spricht von Dermatomen.
Das sind ja sozusagen die Kartografie auf der Haut der Nerven.
Jetzt haben wir vielleicht einen Neurologen unter uns.
Wo ich aber doch etwas von Neurologen gehört.
Oder Internisten, auf welcher Höhe ungefähr könnte dieser Prolabs vorliegen?
Jawohl, fünf, sechs oder sechs, sieben.
Sehr gut.
Gut geraten oder gut gewusst?
Und die Safferenzialdiagnosen kommen eine Fibromialgie.
Und Menschen, ja, unwahrscheinlich, aber okay.
Was noch?
Nur eine Servikalgie.
Okay, warum muss man noch denken?
Wenn man wahnsinnig starke Schmerzen an der Wirbelsäule hat,
was kann es noch sein?
Haben wir Onkologen unter uns?
Was ist das für eine Erkrankung?
Aus der Auserkrankung?
Also irgendeine bösartige Erkrankung im Knochen, natürlich.
Das heißt eine Metastase im Wirbelkörper, zum Beispiel kann es sein.
Auch daran muss man denken.
An einen Tumor, was auf den Nerv drückt.
Ein Neurologischen Tumor, einen Knochentumor,
einen Muskultumor.
Also verschiedenste Tumor-Sorten, auch daran muss man denken, natürlich.
Eine Listease heißt eine Listeasis, zum Beispiel eine Wirbelkörperverschiebung,
wobei das macht jetzt nicht so stark geschmissen,
aber natürlich auch daran muss man denken.
Vorhin hat ein Kollege gefragt, ob Stuhl oder Haaren in Kontinents oder
Darmen in Kontinents.
Weswegen fragt man danach, was kannst du welche Diagnose an,
woher muss man denken, wann hat man Haaren oder eine Darmen in Kontinents
bei einer Spinalkanal?
Stenose.
Genau.
Auch wiederum entweder durch Bandscheibe, durch Tumor.
Was gibt es noch?
Einfach mal eine Nervenlokale, Meningeop, genau, das sind jetzt die Tumore.
Das sind die verschiedensten Neurologischen Tumore.
Aber eine Lokade, eine Muskelverspannung,
wo es vielleicht ganz einfach ist,
und der Patient verspürt es aber als sehr starke Schmerzen.
Vielleicht könnte man etwas Schweres gehoben,
etwas schweres getragen,
komisch gelegen,
auch einfache Sachen können so etwas machen.
Gibt es noch eine?
Also eine Muskelverspannung.
Ja, jetzt verstehe ich.
Eine Interkostale Neurologie.
Kannst gleich sowas machen.
Aber meist muskelverspannende Schulterprobleme.
Ja, eventuell.
Muskel-Lzerationen, also das nennt sich dann
Muskelverspannung, würde man her sagen.
Okay.
Wenn der Patient sagt, dass er eine Magenschmerz habe,
ich vermute, dass die Schmerzen wegen einer
Akutes-Coronarsendronen verursacht wird.
Aber es gibt keine Risikofaktoren.
Genau, aber natürlich muss man auch
einen Herzinfarkt auch denken.
Das kann ja auch manchmal sehr stark
Rückenschmerzen auslösen,
insbesondere wann.
Was war eine Art von Infarkt, kann Rückenschmerzen...
Inferior.
Inferior, also ein Hinterwandinfarkt.
Man kann sich manchmal auch mit Rückenschmerzen häusern.
Das stimmt.
Daran habe ich jetzt wenig gedacht, aber klar,
das ist auch eine Differenzialdiagnose.
Vielleicht ist das der Grund.
Mit Aufstrahlung und linken Namen.
Er hat keine Enge auf der Brust, hat keine
anderen Risikofaktoren, aber als Differenzialdiagnose
sollte man natürlich auch daran denken.
Das stimmt.
Wir haben einige Patienten gehabt, die sind mit
Rückenschmerzen in die Praxis gekommen.
Und das hat sich als ein Herzinfarkt herausgestellt.
Das stimmt.
Sehr gut ein Einwurf.
Wunderbar.
Daran muss man denken, richtig.
Ich glaube, wir haben jetzt einige Differenzialdiagnose.
Man muss, wie gesagt, ich hatte auch einige Patientin.
Die hatte sehr stark Rückenschmerzen,
ähnlich wie dieser Patient.
Und das war dann später
eine Metastase im Wirbelkörper.
Und der Primärtumor war ein...
Ich war mir nicht sicher, ob es ein Dicktamtumor
oder Pankreastumor war.
Ich glaube, das war ein Pankreastumor.
Die war auch Ende 40 und ist auch relativ schnell verstorben.
Ich verstehe.
Wir hatten einen jungen Mann vor einem halben Jahr
in der Praxis.
Der kam auch immer mit Schmerzen.
Und was kam daraus?
Er hatte eine Colizistitis gehabt.
Ja, Sie lachen.
Wir haben den noch gewundert.
Er hatte eine eintrige Colizistitis gehabt.
Und wenn er die Gallblase raus war,
waren auch die Schmerzen weg.
Wo waren die Schmerzen im Rückenbereich?
Der kam immer mit Rückenschmerzen.
Untere BWS, der akzeptierte, da tut es mir, da tut es mir.
Da war er beim Orthopäe.
Da war er bei uns.
Wir haben ihm Spritzen gegeben.
Wir haben ihm Schmerzmedikamente gegeben.
Auch im Labor war nichts Auffälliges.
Aber dann später musste er notfallmäßig ins Krankenhaus.
Und da haben die festgestellt,
dass er in der Praxis war,
weil er erhöhte Laborwerte, Leberwerte und Infektwerte hatte.
Das war die Gallblase.
Wir hatten aber auch eine junge Frau,
die immer mit Lumbalgie in die Praxis kam.
Und letztendlich hat sich dann rausgestellt,
dass sie eine Endometriose hatte.
Und nach der Operation der Endometriose war alles wieder weg.
Nur Lumbalgie?
Nur Lumbalgie.
Und aber auffällig war,
dass sie immer im Rahmen ihrer Periode waren,
die Schmerzen immer stärker.
Also auch ganz interessant.
Sehr gut.
Auflösung dieser Patient, der war auch gestern da.
Was machen wir mit dem Patient?
Michael Diagostik?
Wir gehen des Verdachts auf ein HWS Dispustrolaps.
Für mich zuerst eine körperliche Untersuchung.
Mit Fokus auf der BWS Untersuchung.
Okay, weitere Diagnostik.
Und außerdem veranlasse ich eine MRT Untersuchung.
Sehr gut.
Aus dem Neck und Obererücken.
Also HWS, BWS, ja?
Ja.
Sehr gut.
Und das haben wir auch gemacht.
Was hat er?
Der hat einen ausgeprägten Dispustrolaps HWK67.
Mit einer starken Eingang des Spinalkanals.
Und wir haben ihm zum Neurusschirurgen geschickt.
Die wollten aber nicht operieren.
Wir haben gesagt, erst mal konservativ, mit Medikamenten.
Und wenn es nicht besser wird, dann okay.
Das ist nicht gleich operiert.
Die Operation ist nicht eine gute Entscheidung, ich denke auch.
Ja, wenn man aber ein Papriese hat, wenn man sehr stark geschossen hat.
Und auch im radiologischen Befund einen ausgeprägten Vorfall
oder eine Protrosion hat, dann würden wir schon operieren.
Ja, aber das ist auch gefährlich.
Das ist klar, es ist ein Risiko-OP, aber ein Chirurg operiert gerne.
Aber ich fand es gut, dass der Chirurg gesagt hat, nein, warten wir erst mal.
Das finde ich gut.
Ich auch.
Das war sehr gut, Sie haben die Prüfung bestanden.
Ich hoffe auch.
Vielen Dank.
Sehr gut.
Die Grammatik ist gut, die deutsche Sprache ist gut.
Und von daher denke ich, dass Sie Ihre Prüfung bestanden.
Wir erwarten alle auf eine positive Nachricht von Ihnen.
Ich hoffe auch. Vielen Dank.